mais le débat sur france 24 consacré à
la visite du roi des belges philippe en
rdc une visite de six jours qui durent
donc jusqu'à dimanche est déjà qualifiée
d'historique en raison notamment de son
discours à kinshasa dans lequel il a
renouvelé ses profonds regrets pour
l'exploitation le racisme et les
violences infligées lors de la
colonisation
le roi philippe n'a pas néanmoins
présenter des excuses officielles
il est accompagné de la reine mathilde
et du premier ministre alexander de croo
après kinshasa il se rendra demain à
lubumbashi dans le katanga et à bukavu
dans le kivu le roi philippe a été
accueillie plutôt chaleureusement par le
président félix tshisekedi et par la
population de la capitale alors que
penser de son discours à kinshasa
va-t-il s'ouvrir sur une réconciliation
entre les deux pays que cela concerne la
belgique la france ou encore l'allemagne
comment tirer les leçons du passé pour
construire l'avenir on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés et catherine coquery vidrovitch
bonsoir à vous vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de l'afrique professeur
émérite à l'université paris diderot
auteur de plusieurs ouvrages et vous
avez notamment supervisé la série
documentaire les routes de l' esclavage
c'était pour arte bonsoir à vous et
bienvenus alfred tumba shango lokoho
bonsoir je sois un professeur à
l'université sorbonne nouvelle paris iii
bienvenue à vous également nous avons en
direct de kinshasa avec nous bob kabamba
bonsoir professeur de sciences
politiques à l'université de liège
directeur de la cellule d'appui
politologique en afrique centrale
bienvenue à vous également et puis nous
avons en direct de gand en belgique kris
bervoets bonsoir chercheur belge
spécialiste de l'afrique centrale
bienvenue à vous également
bonsoir vous pouvez tous bien sûr réagir
sur
pendant tout au long de l'émission sur
les réseaux sociaux hashtag débat france
24 on va d'abord faire une sorte de
point sur ce qu'est la rdc la rdc la
république démocratique du congo c'est
un pays qui est quatre fois grand comme
la france donc un très grand pays et
c'est aussi le pays francophone le plus
peuplé d'afrique il faut savoir tout de
même cette géographie parce que c'est
immense effectivement la rdc le roi des
belges philippe en est à son troisième
jour de visite de visite donc on rdc
vous voyez maintenant cette carte je
vous propose justement avant de
commencer le débat d'écouter un extrait
de son discours un extrait du discours
du roi des belges c'était hier à
kinshasa
on l'écouté
[Musique]
il existait
pas ce pauvre paumé
et elle
je vous dise
je sais
oui
même le
pour préserver ses fans
bob
kabamba vous êtes avec nous donc à
kinshasa je voudrais d'abord vous faire
intervenir il avait déjà exprimé ses
regrets le roi philippe il y a deux ans
ce discours est il néanmoins historique
et comment at il été accueilli à
kinshasa donc en pleuvoir au fait ce
discours comme la continuité justement
de la lettre qu'il avait adressée au
président félix tshisekedi
il y a deux ans néanmoins ce qu on peut
souligner c'est que lors de ce discours
il est allé un peu plus loin que c'est
que le contenu de la lettre notamment en
évoquant même des mots assez forts de
racisme de régime discriminatoire et qui
a eu comme conséquence d'exploitation et
l'humiliation des congolais par ailleurs
aussi faut noter que
regardent encore une fois les images et
le ton de sa voix on sent bien qu'il l'a
dit vraiment que ça venait du fond de
son coeur et que c'était inde avec une
grande franchise et donc la nouveauté
ici c'est le fait de s'exprimer devant
le peuple congolais qui était
représentée au niveau de la chambre
c'est là que réside cette nouveauté
c'est une première c'est historique
parce que c'est une première et surtout
lorsque cela concerne un passé aussi
douloureux que l'époque de l'état
indépendant du congo et aussi à pendant
la période coloniale à partir de 1908 et
comment at il été accueilli à kinshasa
on a vu tout de même une foule assez
bienveillante en tout cas oui la foule a
été bienveillante ovono vous devez
savoir que pour l'instant la plupart des
deux des gens à kinshasa évoquons voir
particulier attendre beaucoup de la
belgique pendant tout un temps ils ont
eu l'impression que la politique avait
abandonné le congo est donc il ya cette
attente et qui s'est manifestée de
manière très claire avec l'arrivée donc
du roi et cette attente veut dire aussi
on en attend beaucoup et que la
déception ne pourra pas être de mise du
fait que la belgique s'est aussi engagé
à pouvoir essayer dans la mesure du
possible à répondre aux attentes de la
population notamment les les questions
de la sécurité à l'est les conditions
sociales difficiles que vivent les
congolais actuellement chris bear voûte
vue de belgique justement est ce qu'on
peut dire que ce roi tranche avec son
père et son grand-père est ce que
finalement ces regrets sont liées aussi
à sa personnalité est ce qu'il veut lui
tourner la page
bon ça c'est clair on a constaté celle
ya deux ans quand des façons que
inattendue il a déjà exprimé ses regrets
dans une lettre personnelle
applaudissent à ce moment là est
la différence avec
ses prédécesseurs son père son oncle
c'est très clair mais beaucoup de gens y
compris moi-même avec quand même espérer
que le voit irait un peu plus loin c'est
important qu'il est venu dire place à
kinshasa c'est extrêmement
significative pour pour pau pour tout le
monde mais
beaucoup de gens avaient quand même
espérer que il présenterait
officiellement des excuses de regret
sans excuse bon je ne suis pas sûr c'est
que ça pourrait signifie en fait donc je
ne peux pas cacher mon une certaine
déception le roi a abordé certains
thèmes mais il est resté il est resté
très très prudent je crois une
professeure qu'avant madila ariane il a
accusé certains thèmes qu'il n'avait pas
encore utilisés avant il aurait pu aller
un peu plus loin en garde il ya des
crimes contre l'humanité vraiment qu'ils
ont été commis il n'aurait pu être plus
explicite sur le rôle de son pays et ne
pas oublier le rôle de la dynastie dont
il fait partie aussi les regrets c'est
ce n'est pas assez en vous dit alfred
tumba shango lokoho vous pouvez peut
être réagir comment vous êtes d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire chris bear
vous tous pour vous ce discours est un
tournant alors c est un tournant sans
l'être vraiment
il fallait qu'il aille plus loin
exactement moi je suis un peu
désappointé parce que je m'attendais
effectivement à ce que
le roi a un peu plus loin après deux
années d'empêchement pour aller à
kinshasa on espérait effectivement qu'il
irait un peu plus loin d'autant qu'il
est c'est à dire il présente des excuses
c'est vraiment des mots qui a manqué
encore que ça n'est pas rédhibitoire qui
n'est pas utilisé le mot mais ce que je
voudrais ajouter c'est que ce qui
apparaît aujourd'hui comme une nouveauté
déjà en
1909 au moment où albert 1er il est
encore prince
des de belgique fait son premier voyage
dans la colonie parc à bruz ils avaient
décidé de sortir du protocole et de
marché de rencontrer la population
il avait déjà pointé se fait justement
des crimes contre l'humanité des
violences de léopold 2 et dans son
retour en belgique ça c'était resté dans
sa tête et au fond au moment où il
devient roi des belges il effectué deux
voyages au congo et 1928 et 1932 et où
il revient profondément encore là dessus
pour dire il ya la responsabilité
évidemment à de la monarchie belge en
tout cas de son arrière
grand père
leopold de léopold deux fois là et que
il revenait à la belgique justement deux
à pouvoir pour sa propre prendre sa part
de responsabilité dans les changements
la transformation au congo donc
aujourd'hui
je pense effectivement que albert pardon
à philippe s'inscrit dans cette lignée
là contrairement à ce que son père avait
raté en 1960 au moment de l'indépendance
donc un progrès mais peut-être pas
suffisant vous êtes d'accord catherine
coquery vie trop vite vous voyez
vraiment favorable mais non dans les
rangs des élus refusent un pardon oui et
non dans la mesure où
il s'agit d'une responsabilité de de
l'état par conséquent du roi des belges
elle est de l'ensemble de la belgique
sur ce qui s'est passé qui est
effectivement
extraordinairement d'une part étudier
connu est totalement scandaleux je me
demande si des excuses
veulent dire quelque chose il n'ya pas à
s'excuser c'est inexcusable
c'est un peu ma position on ne s'excuse
pas de quelque chose il n'exclut ni est
excusable on se reconnaît comme
responsable en tant que étals chefs
d'état et je ne sais pas s'il a cédé 15
mai avec à ses regrets ou pas des
regrets c'est pas des reconnaissant une
reconnaissance de responsabilité
donc oui je pense qu'il aurait dû aller
un peu plus loin
sur des fêtes qui sont archiconnus
maintenant très étudiée au moins trois
ouvrages dont 2 grand public qui est
décrit dans le détail tous qui s'est pas
mal de choses qui sont passés qui ont
été absolument épouvantable avec des
mutilations avec des morts etc etc donc
regret c'est évidemment et regrette mais
enfin c'est un petit peu fait mais il a
ajouté il a mis toute une série de
l'adjectif pour dire que c'était tout à
fait on a parlé des excuses il ya sion
ces écrits d excuse moi ça me paraît pas
le mot juste non plus parce que parce
que c'est comme je vous disais c'est
inexcusable donc il n'est pas clair
c'est à dire que vous pensez qu'il
aurait fallu qu'ils disent à l'état
belge est responsable des crimes majeurs
je pense que ça m'a aidé à sion plus
fort baup car gave kabamba pardon vous
êtes d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit oui il faut bien se rendre compte
quand on parle effectivement par rapport
à cette période là il ya deux périodes
qu'il faut prendre en considération
il ya la période de l'état indépendant
du congo c'est à dire plus ou moins la
partie du moment où ce temps l'ayant et
qui met de couvre le le congo et au et
jusque 1901 8 et là nous avons un état
indépendant du congo l'état indépendant
du congo qui a comme son fief d'état
l'enceinte du du droit actuel philippe
et donc il y as période là ces exactions
là que la belgique ne veut pas assumer
cette période là en disant c'est une
gestion personnelle comme on r'n'b de
léopold ii dans ce cas rare sur cette
question là sur cette période là je
pense que le roi philippe peu de manière
claire demander pardon ou des excuses
par rapport à cette période-là puisqu'il
s'agit d'une responsabilité liée à la
dynastie et à la famille royale et
d'autre part il y en a pas de la partie
de 1908 jusque 1960 où c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement belge est
donc en faisant ces deux de deux pas je
pense que le roi philippe aurait pu
aurait pu aussi parler de cette période
là où c'est une responsabilité de la
dignité de la dose de la dynastie de
la famille royale de belgique donc pas
suffisamment clair chris chris bear
voûte vous pouvez ainsi recevant ce qui
vient d'être dit j'ai vu tout de même
qu'en belgique à une commission
parlementaire spéciale qui a été mise en
place avec la rédaction d'un rapport
avec un inventaire notamment des
exactions et des spoliations qui ont été
commises pendant la période coloniale
une commission qui explore aussi des
mécanismes de réparation donc un peu il
ya deux aspects ya la fois le côté
inventaire et le côté réparation et puis
il ya aussi la question de la
restitution d'objets artistiques à la
rdc donc ça fait beaucoup
ou pas
donc oui ce tout à fait donc on est en
train de d'attendre
les résultats et les avancées de de la
commission parlementaire et donc voilà
on attend le résultat
je ferai attention à ne pas réduire les
effets de la colonisation au crime
contre l'humanité on doit quand même
bien comprendre de quoi on parle la
colonisation ça veut dire que il ya des
sociétés qui ont été coupés de leur
propre histoire un ou des processus de
construction d'un des nations d'une
société ont été arrêtés pour intégrer
ces communautés dans une dans un rôle
soumis dans l'histoire de quelqu'un
d'autre du colonisateur alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
nous dans ces cas là en tant que la
belgique on n'aurait jamais pu arriver à
un tel niveau de prospérité
sans la colonisation et on voit
les conséquences de la colonisation
sont aussi au niveau des états faibles
convoi dans l'est dans les ex colonies
et malheureusement le le congo et et
parmi les exemples les plus les plus
dramatiques donc donc jeunes se sont il
ya beaucoup de choses qui doivent être
prises en compte si on parlait de
l'impact de les faire de la
mais notre colonisation
oui je vais vous interrompre pour faire
réagir alfred tumba shango lokoho qu'on
puisse avancer un petit peu on a vu
d'ailleurs ces images on a l'impression
que le fantôme de patrice lumumba plane
sur cette visite je ne sais pas ce que
vous en pensez il a été assassiné le 17
janvier 1961 dans la province du katanga
avec la complicité présumée de la cia du
m16 britannique et de la belgique il
puis y est question justement de
restituer ces restes ça fait partie
effectivement dû d'un vrai sujet pendant
cette visite alors jusqu'à présent on en
a pas parlé mais effectivement l'ombre
de lumumba est toujours là j'espère que
le roi en se rendant à lubumbashi au
katanga pour en dire un mot en tout cas
ce que ça devrait passer au katanga
exactement et donc là le président
tshisekedi est passé rapidement la du un
dévot quand le mamba
et la vivacité encore de la mémoire de
l'oms elle est encore très vive
absolument il est elle et elle est très
vivant et tout le monde attend justement
le retour entre guillemets de cette
relique un de la dent à 2
le combat mais moi je dirai au fond de
mon bas pour la rd congo ce n'est pas
vraiment le vrai problème puisque
lumumba dépasse le congo il n'appartient
ni à sa famille ni au congo il
appartient à l'afrique et lappartient au
monde partout à travers le monde on lui
a rendu des hommages il ya même
l'université lumumba à mouscron le mono
sauf et donc
c'est un problème qui sera vite réglé au
niveau national et des dispositions sont
prises dans ce sens là mais un rapport
quand même d'une commission denquête qui
dit que quiconque lui qui a conclu à la
responsabilité morale de la belgique
dont l'assassinât absolument est
d'ailleurs le gouvernement belge je ne
sais plus 6 de guy verhofstadt avait
reconnu après l enquête parlementaire
sénatoriale qui avait été mené à
l'époque reconnu la responsabilité de la
belgique avait présenté des excuses pour
ce qui concerne l'assassinât de lumumba
et que aujourd'hui c'est encore en cours
parce que probablement il y aura un
procès en belgique mais en rd congo ce
qui les intéresse mais c'est là prêts à
lui mon bac s qui va se passer et
justement après cette visite
du du roi et de la reine par rapport à
la question sociale à la question
culturelle à la question politique
économique etc de r&d com quels seraient
les retombées justement de cette visite
pour réparer un certain nombre de
situations qui sont liées
doublement à la période de à léopold ii
et à la période coloniale à proprement
parler donc là sont parlé de réparations
financières
probablement probablement catherine
coquery vidrovitch est-ce que des
réparations financières sont prévues on
sait qu'il ya aussi des réparations
peut-être à l'égard de femmes métisses
puisqu'il ya eu donc à un procès qui a
été
qui a été entrepris par un certain
nombre de femmes métisses on sait aussi
que l'allemagne par exemple a reconnu
avoir commis un génocide en l'ère
coloniale et elle a versé plus d'un
milliard d'euros à la namibie est ce que
c'est un exemple à suivre pour la
belgique et des la reconnaissance
des méfaits du régime de léopold et de
toutes les suites
qui en ont résulté implique
effectivement
des reconnaissances
plus concrète que simplement
reconnaître que c'était honteux de santé
mais je pense que rennes il y aurait
deux choses à faire
malgré tout on a parlé de mon bas mais
on est on évoque plus ce qui a été
absolument
admirable à l'époque c'est le discours
de lumumba qui a provoqué d'ailleurs sa
mort parce qu'il a trop peu irrité à la
fois les belges et les américains et
tout ceci est connu je suis un petit peu
dubitative sur la pa dubitatif quand on
cherche toujours on trouve toujours des
archives nouvelle quand on cherche mais
sur les nouveautés que pourrait apporter
une autre enquête parlementaire alors
que tant de travaux très approfondies
ont déjà été dit sur la question comme
la soirée voire laquelle on la connaît
ces questions c'est un petit peu dire
ben on va refaire ci a été fait ou va
reprendre les dossiers on va vérifier si
on trouve quelques archives
supplémentaires ce qui est possible et
probable parce que le la l'ouverture des
archives sur la question était
extrêmement réticente pendant très
longtemps par le gouvernement vers le
mans belge est maintenant à son meilleur
mais maintenant on passons à autre chose
un restitution ce discours qui est une
bonne le discours de lumumba de l'époque
qui est d'une modernité extraordinaire
aujourd'hui il serait prononcé tout le
monde serait d'accord
tedeschi recevable en 1970 ce discours
c'est ce qui a provoqué sa mort en
réalité c'est ce sont les mots qu'ils
utilisent
vous savez il existe sur internet il ya
un disque qui est sorti ne s'est pas
difficile de le trouver et il fait le
procès de la colonisation le procès en
particulier du régime de léopold dans
des termes très précis et très exact
comme on le ferait aujourd'hui c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire dans le monde bat
jamais il avait déjà compris à l'époque
on dit
dénonce dans ce discours là non
seulement la route les humiliations
l'apartheid pratiquement qui était
appliqué aux congolais et toutes ces
offenses justement qui ont fait que au
moment de l'indépendance et qu il a dit
les congolais ont arraché l'indépendance
à napa est un don de la belgique
justement parce qu'il ya une lutte à
haute et il ya eu des morts il ya eu des
victimes et par conséquent il fallait
rétablir justement c'est cette mémoire
la du congolais de leur lutte acharnée
contre la colonisation belge bob kabamba
il faut le ressortir ce discours de
lumumba oui il faudrait sortir et vous
allez vous rendre compte que le discours
de le moment dans l'impression que le
roi a puisé toute une série quand même
deux termes qui avait dans ce discours
qui ont été proposés à leurs voix il ya
eu un certain parallèle puisque lumumba
dénonce justement l'état colonial
dénonce les conditions dans lesquelles
on apprécie les délais les congolais
pendant toute cette période dénonce
aussi la période de leur poule tiennent
et alors on a vraiment l'impression que
il ya un parallélisme entre ces deux cd
discours alors ce qui est assez étonnant
on a l'impression que le roi philippe
pour actuelle a essayé d'une certaine
façon de réconcilier le combat et avec
son oncle le roi a beau dire comme vous
le savez à partir du 30 juin
lorsque ce discours a été prononcé on a
insisté véritablement à une rupture
entre les deux équipes qui a conduit à
l'assassinât de lumumba à plus ou moins
quelques mois après et donc c'est
vraiment un discours révolutionnaire et
qui était visionnaire et qui était à
bande d'artistes malheureusement et que
personne n'avait compris encore à ce
moment là on n'était pas prédisposé à
pouvoir écouter ce genre de discours il
faut bien aussi se rendre compte qu'il
ya aussi une évolution au niveau de la
belgique ces listings entendu en
belgique parce qu'il ya eu évolution de
l'opinion publique de plus les
événements aux états unis donc on a vu
qu au niveau belge on a accepté on
commence maintenant accepter à se
remettre en cause par rapport à ce passé
puisque c'est passé a été ignorée oublié
et même deux fois même cacher pour ne
pas être même enseigné par exemple dans
les universités en c'est nier même dans
l'école secondaire ou aux primaires vous
pouvez poser la question à n'importe
quel jeune buzz et vous dira mais ne
connais rien par rapport à la période
coloniale c'est un pays qui se souvient
que le bo est une économie une colonie
est belge et donc tout ça je pense que
vraiment en de visiteurs ce discours on
va bien se rendre compte que ben
effectivement si l'éternel chris bear
voûte vous êtes d'accord donc un
discours avant gardiste est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça change en belgique est
ce qu'on va pouvoir passer à autre chose
comme le demande catherine coquery
vidrovitch sur ce plateau est ce qu'on
enseigne est ce qu'on enseigne justement
cette histoire maintenant dans les
écoles en belgique avec est ce qu'on
enseigne ce discours de lumumba je
crains que nombre le heureux a dit dans
son discours plusieurs fois
on va se concentrer sur le futur on a
aurait great le passé on tourne la page
on va se focaliser sur le futur mais moi
je ne suis pas vraiment d'accord avec ça
je pense que là on doit on doit réécrire
l'histoire coloniale on doit le faire
dans un esprit
décolonisons 1 et on n'a pas fait ça et
le discours du roi ne va pas dans cette
direction je trouve que le passé comme
le professeur cas vendredi devrait être
à chiner et est enseignée ni connu et le
roi aurait pu être beaucoup plus
explicite aussi sur la personnalité de
l'homme mahina mentionné mais on est à
dix jours de la restitution de la dent
de l'ombre
je trouve l'hommage il aurait eu il
aurait pu être un hommage beaucoup plus
explicite sur la personne ont été
ironique de patrice le monde le voit un
rating possibilités importantes alfred
tumba shango lokoho oui vous allez
réagir je serai expliqué un petit peu là
d'en expliquer un peu les circonstances
de cet assassinat et puis ces tortures
il a été torturé patrice lumumba pour
les téléspectateurs qui ne connaissent
pas bien l'histoire du congo oui ivi
d'accord après son arrestation à thé
slits
61 61 il est transporté de kinshasa avec
maurice au polo
jusq u'à elisabethville là il est livré
aux autorités provinciales du katanga et
il est torturé et puis
amenés à devant le peloton tirant les
élimine tous les trois et puis on
découpe en morceaux et on l'aimé
attendez l'acide
et pour dissoudre leur dissoudre leur
corps avant cela il ya un deux bourreaux
qui arrache une des ses dents comme
trophées et jusque il y a quelques
années en belgique un moment où
justement le dossier est ouvert pour le
procès
ce monsieur avant sa mort a reconnu
effectivement de tenir là-dedans de
lumumba qu'il avait arrachée et que donc
voila comme la famille de lumumba
biologique le demandait il fallait leur
restituer cette dent et donc c'est cette
dent qui va être restituée dans une
dizaine de jours restant seulement et
c'est important ça c'est tout à fait
important surtout pour sa famille qui
voudrait justement faire définitivement
le deuil de lemont bas et puis c'est
assez symbolique aussi pour la
république démocratique du congo on a
créé le monde a et ronald en 1966 mobutu
à cette époque là et que donc maintenant
on va lui offrir une sépulture en
allouera dans son village natal
je crois que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de symbolique
catherine coquery vidrovitch pour parler
des réparations est ce que la belgique
doit effectivement aller plus loin en
terme de réparation financière
alors toute la question est de savoir
quel type de réparations financières
pour qui et pourquoi c'est ça qui est
très compliqué ça a été fait dans
beaucoup de
l'ancienne puissance coloniale ou pas
coloniale mais responsable par exemple
de la ségrégation raciale aux états unis
il ya eu d un certain nombre de grandes
firmes étasunienne qui ont vécu de
l'économie sucrière de d esclavage qui
ont apporté des grandes de très fortes
sommes pour soutenir par exemple
l'éducation les bourses de d'étudiantes
ou d'enfants noirs américains qui en
avaient besoin mais pour l'art est
difficile de 2 c'est quasiment
impossible de trouver qui est
responsable de quoi et qui a besoin de
quoi c'est d'une façon
général comme disait notre collègue
la la colonisation belge et ses horreurs
ont pesé sur l'ensemble du pays et
l'ensemble du pays en a souffert alors
plus ou moins et donc au brésil si vous
voulez l'idée a été de consacrer des
sommes particulièrement importante pour
les catégories sociales défavorisées la
population disant que finalement les
défavorisés j'étais en général des
descendants d esclaves et que par
conséquence trompez pas beaucoup en
favorisant les diplômes sa demande au
vietnam aura effectivement de définition
de la cible que ça la concerne en tout
cas la belgique la france ou encore
l'allemagne comment tirer les leçons du
passé pour construire l'avenir c'est
tout de même ça aussi la question qu'on
va se poser est ce qu'on va vers une
réconciliation entre la belgique et la
rdc on va écouter alexandre de croo le
premier ministre belge qui accompagne le
roi de belgique en rdc il a évoqué la
question la souveraineté de la rdc on
écoute
savez chaque pays a le droit de défendre
alors c'est un sujet qu'on connaît très
bien
c'est quand qu'on parle de la situation
devrait toujours un jeu plein droit
d'apprécier
je ne vois pas comment ça serait
différent ici en rdc
vous avez le droit d'exiger
pouvoir que votre territoire
bob kabamba là il parle de l'avenir bien
sûr le premier ministre belge et c'est
un disque ou est ce qu'il ya des accords
en d2 défense en jeu aujourd'hui entre
la rdc et la belgique on sait que ces
accords avaient été rompues me
semble-t-il par kabila
pour employer le terme exact par à
kabila et lorsque le président félix ce
qui est dit est arrivé au pouvoir en
fait il a réactivé les différents
accords de coopération en matière de la
matière sécuritaire et vous devez savoir
aussi que présentement il ya quand même
25 militaires belges qui sont présents
sur le sol congolais et qui sont en
train de faire ce qu'on appelle une
remise une remise à niveau des troupes
qui avaient été formés il y à quelques
quelques années il faut souligner aussi
sur cette question là lorsqu'on aborde
effectivement la question de l'intégrité
territoriale lymphome est interprété
comme un appui de la belgique au congo
contre ce que le congo considère comme
une agression du rwanda est certainement
je suis sûr que dans les jours ou les
semaines à venir du côté rwandais ne
vont pas nécessairement prendre ça de
bon coeur et qui vont certainement avoir
à remettre ça entre les relations entre
la belgique et le rwanda si cet aspect
des choses là c'est aussi en lien avec
les populations de l'est le discours de
l'intégrité aussi par rapport aux
populations de l'est il souffre
justement de cette situation de la
sécurité et qui attendent un signal qui
attendent un message fort de la belgique
pour justement les soutenir dans les
caves de tout des du conflit qui est
naissant entre le congo et le rwanda
chris bear voûte est effectivement on
sait qu'il va se déplacer le roi le roi
philippe il va aller dans qui vous est
donc pas loin de cette zone justement où
il ya une guerre depuis 25 ans avec des
exactions qui sont commises est ce qu'il
va pouvoir s'engager en faveur
finalement de la rdc et contre le rwanda
parce que là c'est un peu ce qu'on a
ressenti dans ce discours même s'il n'a
pas cité le rwanda
c'est effectivement c'est très important
la phrase qu'il acquit maps ou non c'est
parce que c'est une question qui
préoccupe beaucoup de gens et avec un
potentiel de
d'explosivité une régionale qui dépasse
qui dépasse le congo je pense aussi que
le fait qu'ils visitent bukavu est très
important
le fait qu'il va parler avec le
congolais commun avec les victimes il a
déjà permis aujourd'hui avec la société
civile et mouvements féminins
j'espère que
le reste de sa de sa mission va pas
nous donner quelques exemples de
quelqu'un de leroy qui écoute les
victimes qui emmène en belgique comme
témoignage donc si sa mort est
extrêmement important alfred tumba
shango lokoho alors évidemment le rwanda
dit que c'est une guerre interne à la
rdc c'est la façon dont ils se défendent
kagame il va aller voir le docteur
mukwege est d'ailleurs ce week-end le
roi le roi philippe pour parler
justement de ces victimes d'exactions
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
véritablement de la belgique alors il ya
déjà un pas qui a été franchi dans à la
formation des militaires
ensuite cette étape symbolique de ponzi
est une étape importante c'est un signal
fort parce qu'au fond dans l'entendement
de beaucoup de congolais il y avait
cette crainte en fait de la relance de
du m23 à goma donc aux groupes rebelles
c'est ça étant dûment soutenu par le
monde dans le rang d'un exactement
c'était une manière de vouloir saboter
la venue du roi et d'ailleurs même la
venue du pape puisque le pape a décidé
de se rendre à goma et que donc là c'est
un signal fort pour dire et le roi l'a
d'ailleurs évoqué le droit de défendre
l'intégrité de son territoire par la rd
congo et que la belgique allait appuyer
toutes les initiatives diplomatiques
pour résoudre ce problème et en même
temps je crois et c'est là où est la
sagesse du roi de dire oui il faut
trouver des réponses régionales c'est à
dire
des responsables politiques de la région
pour essayer
d'éviter l'embrasement de toute la
région parce que ça serait beaucoup plus
compliqué est-ce que la belgique
pourrait être à l'origine d'une sorte de
va devenir une sorte de médiateur dans
un processus peut-être un peu plus
multilatérale bonjour pour cette
question du kivu je ne pense pas que la
belgique puisse s'impliquer davantage
parce qu'il ya aussi les contentieux
avec le rwanda
lors du génocide même si verhofstadt
avait reconnu à l'époque
présenté des excuses à au rwanda il ya
déjà un passif là entre le rwanda la
belgique et la belgique s'était retirée
justement est d'ailleurs moi je voulais
ajouter c'est toute la contradiction
face à la dure beaucoup des belges mais
aux finalistes l'histoire les rattrape
toujours toujours exactement et moi je
voudrais rappeler effectivement que au
fond pour la belgique le congo compte
beaucoup parce que c'est vraiment de
manière adventices que le rwanda et le
burundi sont devenus des colonies belges
en
1925 mais après la première guerre
mondiale c'était à des deux millions qui
étaient placés par la société des
nations à la disposition de la belgique
est au fond que la la la la la grande
colonie belge le en dehors de la
belgique c'était le congo et c'est
pourquoi il ya là toutes ces visites des
rois régulièrement j'entendais il ya
quelques jours lors des 70 ans de la
reine d'angleterre dire mais elle a
accordé beaucoup d'importance à la
france elle a fait un peu de cinq
visites en france par rapport à tous les
restes des pays du monde les rois belges
eux le font en même temps pour le congo
une réaction comment tirer les leçons du
passé finalement pour construire
l'avenir je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
de très important
dans la réconciliation que vous avez
évoqué entre le congo et la belgique
c'est que il on tue
sans vouloir léser serban quasiment un
siècle de vie commune il ya une histoire
culturelle il ya des liens très
important il ya beaucoup de congolais
qui sont en belgique y en a un certain
nombre qui sont devenus belge il ya un
certain nombre de belges qui ont vécu au
congo vous avez tout une des réalités
culturelles et familiales très
importante et on ne peut pas faire comme
si elle n'avait pas existé je veux dire
que ça ne compte pas ça compte beaucoup
je pense que ça compte évidemment pour
les belges mais ça le mouton qui
tournait cela dit le plan d'eau est ce
qu'une page est tournée avec cette
visite dans un collège l'histoire le
dira mais une page d jamais tourné
ils essayent est loin de tourner une
page de se réconcilier c'est déjà
beaucoup une ré à l'avenir des liens qui
n'ont jamais vraiment disparu en réalité
ne serait ce que par l'ensemble des des
congolais qui dont les descendants sont
toujours en belgique ou réciproquement
donc ça ça ne disparaît pas alors savoir
comment ça va
ceci va pouvoir savourer sa médaille
j'ai progressé dans le futur ces futurs
qu'il dira et c'est la volonté à la fois
des congolais et des belges des belges
offert dans la dans l'entente dans les
échanges et pas dans la subordination ou
comme ça a été le cas d'exploitation bob
kabamba hameau justement c'est une
réconciliation aujourd'hui que on vise
entre les deux pays est ce que cette
visite de six jours tout de même du roi
va aboutir à une sorte de nouvelle étape
dans cette réconciliation
oui ça va aboutir et une nouvelle étape
et encore ils devront tirer une nouvelle
étape mais il faut bien se rendre compte
que par rapport aux relations entre la
belgique et le congo il y avait déjà des
piliers qui existait avant dont
notamment le pilier le plus fort qui
était le pilier économique
malheureusement depuis plusieurs années
on sait que ces piliers économique n'est
plus en belgique mais il est maintenant
du côté donc de de la chine est donc
côté de la chine effectivement est donc
maintenant par rapport à ses relations
il faut les construire différemment sur
d'autres bases alors pour illustrer cet
autre base
je vais juste utiliser deux chiffres et
avec deux périodes différentes en 1960
au congo on avait plus de cent mille
belges qui vivait au congo aujourd'hui
actuellement en belgique on a plus de
100000 on va dire belge d'origine
congolaise qui vivent en belgique et
donc oui il ya possibilité comme
d'ailleurs le roi lui même l'a souligné
dans son discours en mettant l'accent
sur la tempora congolaise qui est
présente en belgique et qui participe à
la création et à la création des
richesses en belgique devient
possibilité de pouvoir construire des
ponts sur ça et aux autres choses où ça
ressemble un petit peu à ce que voulait
faire emmanuel macron d'utiliser les
diasporas
besoin d'exploit qu'il peut être un
pilier important consolidé justement les
relations entre les deux pays par
ailleurs aussi le savons que la belgique
a connu n'a plus les moyens que sont les
nouveaux partenaires congolais comme la
chine ou bien comme les etats-unis ou
bien comme d'autres encore mais la
belgique peut accompagner en fait le
congo dans toute une série de deux
secteurs notamment le secteur minier
notre moment le secteur de
l'environnement qui a été aussi souligné
en disant ben oui la belle peut aider
justement le congo à pouvoir être par
exemple ce pays solution pour contre le
réchauffement un clip atik et dans ce
rôle d'accompagnement que l'on peut
retrouver finalement un partenariat
entre les deux qui ne sera plus non plus
fondée sur un partenariat économique
avec des rapports et qui seraient des
rapports centre périphérie mais en
accompagnant ont serré dans une
dynamique est beaucoup plus égalitaire
que c'est qu'on a connu auparavant à
l'époque par exemple de mobutu bien à
l'époque de kabila père s il faut aller
ce qu'il faut penser aussi que nous
sommes maintenant dans une ère de
mondialisation c'est-à-dire il réagit
plus de rapports entre la belgique et le
congo il s'agit de la place du congo
dans le monde de la place de la belgique
dans le monde et de leurs relations
articulé par rapport au monde donc
c'est vrai puis c'est peut-être vrai qu
historiquement parlant c'est le contenu
de sa petitesse c'est la belgique qui
est perdante dans cette mondialisation
par rapport à la place du congo je n'en
sais rien réservé aux départements on ne
peut plus régler les problèmes belgo
congo congolais en regardant simplement
les deux partenaires stratégiques ça ne
ce n'est plus comme ça christ verbe haut
il faut il réagir c'est vrai que la
chine a supplanté largement la belgique
en tout cas en ce qui concerne toute
l'économie et en particulier dans le
katanga à là où il ya toutes les
richesses du congo bien sûr la chine est
là la chine est le premier dans un pub
et au large de plusieurs nouveaux
partenaires et c'est important que le
monde est devenu multipolaire mais je
vais quand même aussi insisté sur la
croissance en importance des
institutions qui la terreur africaine
moi j'y crois en moi je crois que
l'afrique va se prendre en charge et
j'ai vu autour du congo un intérêt
multilatérale qui sait
qui s'est construit et qui a réussi par
exemple en 2013 de neutraliser même 23
et kiki à qui a pris en main la
reconnaissance de du processus électoral
en 2018 enfin 18 début 19 ans
l'afrique en cocktail a exigé une
appropriation sur le problème congolais
qui est un problème africain et je ne
peux que
applaudir ça je pense que c'est très
important donc on doit quand même
relativiser le rôle d'un pays comme la
belgique voulait conclure si je me
glisse poire en tout cas sur la
possibilité justement de la de
régionaliser ces problématiques bon on
va aller vers la paix en tout cas dans
le oui l'a permettait de la paix déjà un
régionaliser toutes les structures de la
région et pourtant il n'ya pas la taille
par avion mais la difficulté et met
d'ailleurs on l'a vu non seulement ici
mais même en nations unies personne
n'ose nommer le rwanda comme le pays
agresseur et quand on sait que le rwanda
s'est brouillée enfin kagame s'est
brouillé avec tous les chefs d'état de
la région du burundi du kenya de
l'ouganda de la tanzanie est maintenant
de la rd congo on sait qui est le
facteur de trouble quand on sait qu'en
2000 le rwanda et l'ouganda se sont
battus acquis sans gagner dans l'or de
la rd congo on se rend compte
effectivement que c'est un facteur
perturbateur
qu'à cela ne tienne la région s'est
emparé de cette question et est en train
d'essayer de trouver une solution
pacifique de toute façon tu sais qu'elle
dit lui même quand il a pris le pouvoir
et la enclenché cette diplomatie de la
paix on va voir justement quelles
vont-être ses résultats en tout cas vous
avez l'air de dire que ça va vers une
réconciliation en tout cas entre la
belgique et la rdc que cette visite du
roi des belges qui dure dont jusqu'à
dimanche en rdc merci beaucoup catherine
coquery vidrovitch d'abord été avec nous
merci à vous alfred tumba shango lokoho
merci à bob kabamba d'avoir été avec
nous en direct de kinshasa et merci à
vous et chris bear voûte vous étiez avec
nous en direct de gand en belgique merci
à vous tous nous narre suivi et reste
avec nous sur 24